comical as could be but what do you mean
it was funny well you know you know you
sort of say things funny is what I mean
no you you don't mean me you mean the
character was saying well maybe I mean
you
've had them I almost had him I really
don't think the guy was funny
you don't think he was funny I don't
think he was funny
not even mildly amusing
to you he was in New York to me
he was not ask ask Ray Liotta when he
was sitting in that chair that guy was
amusing
and you know why people laughed it was
nervous laughter yeah
that was not amusing
I mean if I was sitting there when uh
when Tommy was going off at Ray Liotta
in the movie I would have probably been
the guy to say yeah oh you didn't mean
it that way you know you know I would
have probably been a guy trying to
lighten the situation well you know I I
don't think he meant funny that way I
mean he's funny you know hey we're all
funny you know I would have found a way
to try to lighten it I think